[موسيقى]
اسمي إيريك ريس فنان
وأعمل أيضًا في معرض الفنون المحبوب في مدينة نيويورك
الذي أحب أبوظبي لأن المشهد
الفني مزدهر وهذا يجعلني أشعر
بالسعادة لكوني أعيش هنا.
افتتحت أبو ظبي
في نوفمبر 2017 ، واستغرق الأمر عشر
سنوات وتكلفت أكثر من 100 مليون دولار
لبناء أول شيء تلاحظه
أن المشي إلى متحف اللوفر أبو ظبي هو
القبة بالطريقة التي يرشح بها الضوء من
خلال القبة
التي توفر المقدار المثالي من
ملاذًا بعيدًا عن أشعة الشمس القاسية ، لذلك
أعتقد حقًا أنه من الرائع أن
تكون القبة العائمة قد صممها
المهندس المعماري جان نوفيل الحائز على جائزة ، وهي
مستوحاة من الأنماط الهندسية العربية ،
إنها مقدمة رائعة
لصالات العرض في بهو لويسفيل ،
يضم متحف اللوفر أبو ظبي روائع
من جميع أنحاء العالم  نقل
الموضوع العالمي للإنسانية في جميع
أنحاء المتحف لوحات فان جوخ
غوغان ومونيه تزين الجدران حقيقة أن
متحف اللوفر أبو ظبي يقدم  تضيف كل هذه
الفترات التاريخية
والتحف والأشياء المختلفة بالطبع إلى
المشهد الثقافي وتضيف أيضًا
إلى المعرفة والتعليم هنا ، أنا
أحب هذه اللوحة بشكل خاص
نظرًا لطريقة عمل الفنان ، لم يتم
رسمها من مشهد حي كان هذا هو
تجمع الأرض بين العناصر المختلفة
وتجمعها معًا لإنشاء
الأمير الشاب الذي يقرأ كتابًا ، ومن
المثير للاهتمام مشاهدة رد فعل الناس
على هذه اللوحة لأنها تحظى
بشعبية كبيرة حتى الأشخاص الذين لا يعرفون الكثير
عن الفن يتعرفون علي
بدراستها في كتب التاريخ و  ثم
رؤية لوحاتهم هنا وهي
تختبر اللوحة بشكل مباشر في الكثير من
تجربة عشاق الفن لطلاب الفن
بشكل عام الذين لديهم اسم كبير مثل Luca
Willoughby بالتأكيد جلبت الكثير من
الاهتمام إلى المنطقة لدينا الكثير من
فناني المعارض والمتصلين وعشاق الفن
ببساطة يزورون  الإمارات بسبب القانون